first comic coming to the stage one of
the hardest-working comics in New York
City young guy and I think you're gonna
like them please welcome mark Normand
everybody Thank You Ricky little Ricky
known for a long time he's really grown
into quite a man there that sounds a
little gay in it it was started by
meeting women all that stuff I'm still
having trouble in that department never
really been good with the whole sexual
thing I was pretty much a dumb kid was
anyone else disappointed when they found
out what have students meant I remember
being a kid to get sex ed class teacher
was like you can't have sex she'll get a
disease you'll get a girl pregnant but
there is an alternative like Jesus not
available we have something and she's
like abstinence like what does that mean
what is that
what what not doing it at all this is
the alternative how does that an
alternative this is decaf is an
alternative margarine is an alternative
you know if there were people with diner
in a bit like M on this toast everyone
1d butter give a plural turn they never
say yes nothing when I listen to
alternative rock station it's not
silence it's different kinds of wrong
[Music]
but you know few years later I
discovered mr. B I was like okay this is
an alternative the only problem is
getting all turned everything friends
real girls fool that's how they get you
you know what I'm talking about
what do we do it with our lives what are
we doing out away Oh guys I got the old
day job at the day job recession hasn't
gotten me yet I hate the day job hate it
to me the worst part is getting up at
the crack of dawn I hate waking up early
I hit that snooze button like eight
times
I love the snooze button I think about
the snooze button do you think the guy
who pitched the idea of the snooze
button was late to the beat Jesus
Johnson you're 20 minutes late
well that's what we talked about don't I
look well-rested I'm gonna change the
world
[Music]
change the world
guys I got a I got a weird pet peeve I
think people use the phrase I don't [ __ ]
around a little too loosely a friend of
mine went down at the corner store he
came back up he was unloading the bags I
was like aa Wheat Thins it was yeah I
don't [ __ ] around
if I wait since I have a [ __ ] around is
a line for a guy who brings a gun to a
knife fight
you bought crackers I think you're
[ __ ] around what is that phrase so
it's like a tough-guy phrase everybody
so quickness in it I don't [ __ ] around I
don't [ __ ] around
I say let's [ __ ] around should be
[ __ ] around more looks like the real
right now really great time next time
somebody says [ __ ] around say well you
should come on you look stressed
loosen up take a load off this is why
you're getting the Night Fights
alright guys I love doing comedy itch in
some weird situations though I did I did
a show up in Philly not too long ago
show it was great but it ran late and I
missed the last train back to New York
so I had to sleep at the station which
was really scary and I'm laying on a
bench and a cop walks by me and I swear
to god he says this keep her covered up
and he's walking he might keep your
guard up you're guarding this place you
learn the door I should be telling you
that keep your guard above sorry little
dude that's
keep my guard you know it's a cop's job
to prevent crime not warn us of it you
know we can't have comes walking around
like my dad he's got a gun
I'll be in my car ah keep your guard up
that's great advice
say you know if I did get mugged you
know the comedies like what did I tell
you come on civilians huh they don't
listen oh boy I love East Village so
this wasn't a farm or Trek for me love
these Philips great place to live it's a
little saucy at night though I was
walking down with my roommate and a
prostitute approached me and my roommate
she was very trashy very sleazy smoking
a cigarette blowing the smoke in her
face and she was hey you boys wanna have
some fun with me for cheap and I was
like no we're okay and she walked away
and as a joke I turned to my friend and
I was like look you and he goes no she
smoked ah is that what got you
jeez it knows the nasty habit over the
whoring the prostituting is what got me
come on I know you don't like girls who
smoke man but your turn off for a little
askew a lot of wack you know that's like
saying I would never [ __ ] a kid with
braces crooked teeth on the kid gross
great teeth handsome boy guys every
night trying to get a little healthier a
perfect drink in the old soy milk soda
drinking old soy milk they say it's
better for you you know I think if
that's the case on the carton that she
would picture the kids we found I
mentioned I live in the East Village at
the Chinese place I'd love to go in my
neighborhood I love Chinese food it's
one of my favorites I love Chinese food
I love it could you get such a big
portion
you always have leftovers I love
leftovers
it's amazing how excited I get from that
white box in the fridge so I'm thinking
about starting a restaurant cult
leftover will serve everything styrofoam
that portion will serve it cold they'll
be a micro better table sometimes those
are empty
hey where those my food your roommate
well I wrote my name on originally well
he's a dick
thanks breeding and leftovers it's
bigger than the Chinese I got into quite
an argument with my roommate the other
day because apparently I've been using a
racial slur that I didn't know is a
racial slur and I feel bad about this I
don't really throw slurs around but I
didn't know but in my defense can we all
agree that the gentlest of the racial
slurs has got to be [ __ ] I know it
has negative connotation I know but he's
from China he's a man not so bad
China's got nothing on the n-word is
what I'm saying here to me I think the
names of Chinese restaurants sound a lot
more like racial slurs let's try some
you know who can't drive those [ __ ]
panda kings and they stink I gonna write
on the train one more Facebook Express
I'm out of this town
they make me sick and listen to this
listen us one of those golden noodles
just with my apartment building who did
right next door to me they're one big
happy family
those guys really burned me up those
lucky dragon it's a fun joke I did that
joke in DC and this Asian guy came up to
me after and he was like hey I would
take it easy with that true you know
Chinese people they don't [ __ ] around
[Laughter]
[Applause]
mark Normand everyone